so it seems at the moment that humanity
is suffering a kind of collective soul
sickness there is a global epidemic of
existential distress the numbers don't
lie anxiety and depression is being
diagnosed at levels we've never seen
before the United Nations in fact has
said that 800,000 people a year now are
committing suicide across the globe that
is a larger number than the amount of
people to die from armed conflict and
natural disasters combined the question
is whether this should surprise us
perhaps our personal narratives our
collective cultural operating system our
cultural narratives about who and what
we are have hit their limit they are no
longer serving us I mean at the end of
the day should this surprise us the
philosopher Tolstoy said that man cannot
live without finding a way to bridge the
finite with the infinite right Kafka
said men cannot live without a
continuous belief of something
indestructible within himself right now
we need to commune with the eternal with
the cosmos in order to impregnate our
life with meaning and signification now
religion used to provide this narrative
the light of this existential blanket
right blanketing us from the void by
telling us we will live forever in the
kingdom of God but increasing
sophistication increasing scientific
awareness and knowledge and increasing
intelligence has actually made us more
anxious because these old narratives are
no longer serving us I believe the
epidemic of depression and anxiety and
general malaise and meaninglessness
comes from this unique awareness that we
are mortal beings but perhaps what we
need is a different story
perhaps what we need
is a cognitive reframing something
really funny happens to astronauts when
they go into orbit
these are secular materialistic
engineers these guys on the back of
science and knowledge who's into the
orbiting of the planet all of a sudden
they see the earth as a single solitary
marble floating in the cosmos they see
everything they've ever known as just
one thing they see themselves and their
planet as one and this psychic
transformation is known as the astronaut
overview effect apparently such a
dramatic change in perspective such a
traumatic recontextualization of what we
are changes us and this ontological
awareness gets rid of the feeling of
meaninglessness and all of a sudden
informs our whole phenomenological
worldview with this idea that we are
part of something greater than ourselves
is a sense of noetic ultimate truth that
goes deeper than everyday reality right
and in that moment that poetic hijacking
of awareness and understanding that
overview effect changes these astronauts
forever so how do we give more of us
this kind of experience to willingly
induce metaphysical mystical experiences
in the labs of psychiatry are we on the
cusp of uncovering a telescope for
psychiatry and for the mind are we gonna
take a novice in the levers approached
by the mentally change our awareness
point B is we need
we need to awaken to our true condition
we to transcend our M menaces which is
the forgetting of the forgetting and
remember what not so this is a call to
upgrade this is a call to attack
yourself this is a call to become some
we are a chrysalis about to turn into a
butterfly we are undergoing a
metamorphosis and are about to spread
our wings we are not a cancer upon a
host planet we are a fetus and this is
our birth canal
it may be bloody it may be turbulent but
we can be reborn anew we can come out of
the other side transform transcended is
our birthright it is a calling it is
beckoning my friends to call to awaken
[Music]